les Ukrainiens se sont une nouvelle fois
réveillés sous une pluie de bomb ici à
kiiefev le centre-ville a été touché par
plusieurs explosions des missiles ont
visé la capitale leurs débris ont fait
beaucoup de dégâts derrière moi vous
voyez une entrée de station de métro qui
a été fortement endommagée ce n'est pas
la première fois qu'elle l'a été déjà
l'an dernier cette ce même endroit avait
été touché j'ai pu parler avec des
citoyens des résidents locaux qui m'ont
expliqué qu'ils avaient tenté de se
mettre à l'abri dans l'un de ces dans
dans cette station de métro ils n'ont
pas eu le temps à cause des des bombes
Kiev n'a pas été la seule ville visée
aux premières heures du jour des
explosions ont également frappé la ville
de l viive dans l'ouest du pays des
immeubles résidentiels ont été touchés à
harkif c'est un hôpital qui été touché
ad Nipro un un centre commercial et des
explosions ont également retenti dans
zoligia et à Odessa cela montre une fois
encore que la Russie continue jour après
jour de bombarder l'ensemble du
territoire ukrainien et que bien souvent
puisqu'on déplore déjà des morts et de
nombreux blessés et bien ce sont les
civils qui pai le prix de cette
agression